>>Presenter: [inaudible] and in September
her book Forget Perfect was featured on the
Today Show and on NBC Nightly News.
Lisa writes leadershipcommunityreport.com
and for major news outlets such as Fortune
and The Wall Street Journal and this is Lisa.
So would you like to take it away?
>>Lisa Earle McLeod: Thanks, thanks.
Well I'm so glad to be here with you all today.
The title of my talk is How to Sell with Noble
Purpose, and so I'm gonna give you the big
idea at the very front end.
And the idea is this: the salespeople who
sell with a sense of higher purpose, that
is the salespeople who are what I call the
true believers, who believe not only in their
products but who also believe in the impact
that they have on their customers, that they
make a difference in the lives of their customers,
those salespeople outperform the salespeople
who are just focused on their quotas or the
money.
And these words selling and noble, a lot of
people don't think that they go together,
in fact, a lot of people think that sales
is anything but noble and when you call someone
"salesy" it's not really a compliment [chuckles]
in most cases.
But I'm here to tell you that they're wrong,
because when they talk about sales from that
perspective they're really just talking about
the number side, the quota side, the spreadsheet
side.
And so what I'm wanna talk to you about is
the whole other side of sales.
And so I wanna share with you the research
I've done and the results of the research
I've done for the last 10 years that prove
beyond a shadow of a doubt that when you have
a larger purpose, when you're part of something
that's bigger than you are, when you know
that what you're doing makes a difference,
you're more effective, you're more assertive,
you're most successful, and you're also happier.
[pause]
And nowhere is this more important than in
sales, because the reality of sales is you
may have a target, a quota, whatever language
you use, that connects with your head.
But when you have a sense of a higher purpose
it connects with your heart which is where
your passion lies.
So I'm gonna make you three promises for today,
I hear a motorcycle revving up [bad audio]
in the background [laughs].
[laughter]
I'm gonna make you three promises for today:
number one I'm gonna show you how you can
bring a sense of purpose and passion to your
job, how you can fall in love with your job;
number two I'm gonna show you how you can
bring that sense of purpose to your customers,
to get your customers more engaged; and number
three how you can bring it to the other areas
of your life and the people that you care
about.
So we got about an hour together, we're gonna
make the most of it.
So here's what I want you to do: we're gonna
start off with an exercise.
So what I want you to do is each of you pick
a partner and I want you to pretend that you
are at a cocktail party or a soccer game whichever
one you would be more likely to be at and
you've been introduced to another person and
they ask that question that they always ask,
"What do you do for a living?"
And I just want you to very briefly describe
what you do and then switch.
OK?
So just do that, don't think about it much,
just answer the question the way you'd ordinarily
answer the question.
[people speaking to each other in background]
[pause]
Hey come on in, you're good.
Uh-hum.
I'm Lisa.
>>male #1: [inaudible] How do you do?
>>Lisa Earle McLeod: Hi, nice to meet you.
Go ahead and have a seat.
[pause]
They're doin' an exercise right now where
I asked them to, no you're good, you're good,
yeah 'cause you're lucky you get to do it
with me now.
>>male #1: [laughs]
>>Lisa Earle McLeod: Imagine, and I'll explain
the background on this in a little bit, we're
talking about how to show up for your customers
with purpose.
So what I want you to do is I want you to
just imagine we're at, we just met, which
we did, and I say, "What do you do for a living?"
And just tell me what you do for a living,
what's your job?
Just answer the way your ordinarily would.
What do you do for a living?
>>male #1: [inaudible]
>>Lisa Earle McLeod: You're a programmer.
Oh where do you work?
>>male #1: [inaudible]
>>Lisa Earle McLeod: Okay, like what?
>>Lisa Earle McLeod: Okay, so you're a programmer
and it's secret.
Okay, I got it, that's good, that's all I
need to know.
[laughs]
[laughter]
And they're takin' turns.
So, okay, so we're good, so pop up your computer
if you wanna take notes on that and we're
good.
[pause]
So did you have a chance to do that?
I want you to remember what that felt like
when you said it and I want you to remember
what it felt like when you heard it.
Chances are you probably had a pretty automatic
response didn't you 'cause that's a question
that we're used to be asked, "What do you
do for a living?"
You guys probably get a better response than
most people because you say, "I work at Google,"
and then they go, "Wow, that's really cool,
wow."
But typically we have a pretty rote response
when it comes to these things.
So I want you to remember how that felt and
we're gonna come back to that.
So now I wanna talk to you about this idea
of selling with noble purpose and how that's
different than the way a lot of people sell.
Now I'm gonna give you a little bit of background
and tell you I am a total nerd about these
things.
I have been studying sales organizations for
over 20 years in a quest to figure out why
some people are good and some people are absolutely
amazing, and I wanted to figure out that difference
so I've been doin' this for a long time.
So I'm really nerdy but this, about the data
and about behavior and all that stuff, so
I'm just giving you that disclaimer on the
front end.
So when was 19 years old I had my first sales
job and I sold advertising for the college
paper and as I said I know you guys sell advertising,
but I sold it when it came in this paper form
like that.
So I sold advertising and then I was the sales
manager for the college newspaper.
And when I was 20 years old I was the sales
manager and our college newspaper sold a million
dollars worth of advertising in one year.
Now I know that's nothing compared to what
you all sell, but for a college newspaper
that is a lot of money [chuckles] that is
like an unheard of amount of money.
So clearly I was on fire for sales.
So after college I went to work for Proctor
& Gamble, I was a salesperson there, won some
sales awards, was the sales manager, and was
the sales trainer.
But I left Proctor & Gamble, big fancy Proctor
& Gamble, multi-national company.
I left there and I went to work for a sales
training company, and it was this little speck
of a sales training company, it was a six
million dollar company compared to Proctor
& Gamble, so obviously very small.
But I went to go work there because I really
believed in what they were doing.
[pause]
And so I went to go work, I was in business
development; I was in charge of business development.
So the first year brought in a million dollars
worth of new business, second year brought
in another million dollars worth of new business.
And so a six million dollar company to bring
in a million dollars in new business two years
in a row is like a big deal, especially a
training company where the margins are like
40 percent.
So I really liked it and I was a believer,
I believed in our programs, but there was
always something missing 'cause we'd go and
we'd do these programs, the sales people would
learn the skills, and inevitably there would
be one small group of people that would outperform
the other people, there would always be those
outliers.
And so I thought, "Something's missing.
I wanna know what this is."
So I started my own company, was doing a lot
of consulting work around the area of sales
leadership, and what I wanna tell you about
it a project that I worked on and that had
a profound experience on my life, the way
I think about sales, and the way I think about
sales leadership.
So I was hired, a group of consultants was
hired by this biotech company, this big biotech
company had sales reps all over the world
and they wanted to know the same thing a lot
of companies wanna know, same thing I wanna
know, what's the difference between the people
that are good at the jobs and people who are
absolutely amazing in terms of sales numbers?
So they hired this group of consultants and
we were gonna go out and we were gonna assess
the salespeople; we were gonna ride with 'em,
follow their calls, do interviews, we did
a whole host of things.
And I should tell you this was a double blind
study in the sense that we didn't know who
the top performers were, we were just looking
at the behavior and this was fascinating.
So there's a lot of ways that you can look
at sales behavior and I'll show a couple of
'em now and these are some pretty basic ways.
When you take a look at sales behavior –
[sound of papers being shuffled]
one thing a lot of people look at is –
[pause]
customer knowledge and product knowledge,
and this is pretty easy to understand.
Think about a salesperson --
[pause]
if you're low on the customer knowledge, low
on the product knowledge how do you think
these people perform?
They're terrible.
This is not rocket science, they're terrible.
Then we have salespeople who are high on customer
knowledge or high on product knowledge rather,
but low on customer knowledge.
What kinds of behavior do you think you see
from those salespeople?
>>male #2: [inaudible]
>>Lisa Earle McLeod: Um-hum.
Um-hum.
Here's my product, here's my product, here's
my goal, here's my number.
Then we have salespeople who may be very high
on customer knowledge, these are more rare,
but low on product knowledge.
What do you think happens there?
>>someone in audience: [inaudible]
>>Lisa Earle McLeod: Um, sometimes, sometimes.
A lot of times these people have trouble closing
the deal 'cause they don't have the technical
expertise.
And then we have the obvious: people who are
high on customer knowledge, high on product
knowledge and those are the people who are
really, really good at their jobs.
And as we looked at that what I realized is
a couple of those people were a lot better;
they didn't necessarily have more customer
knowledge and they didn't necessarily have
more product knowledge, but when we observed
their sales calls the calls were a lot better.
So again what was that thing, what was that
thing that made them different?
So then –
[sound of papers being shuffled]
another typical way, call frequency and call
length.
People that don't make many sales calls and
the ones they make are short, generally get
fired pretty fast, right?
What about the salespeople that make lots
and lots of sales calls but the calls are
relatively short, they don't engage a customer
in much of a dialog?
>>someone in audience: [inaudible]
>>Lisa Earle McLeod: That's okay, depends
on what you sell, it's kinda that spray and
pray, and I'm gonna talk to you and I'm gonna
talk to you, and I'm gonna talk to you and
if I'm persistent enough it's a numbers game,
I'll probably eventually sell something.
And then you have salespeople that have really
long calls with their customers, really in
depth conversations but they don't make that
many calls.
So high close rate with the people they do
call on, the problem is they just don't call
on enough people.
And so then you have these people.
[pause]
They always make a lot of calls and they're
significant calls, they're of a length enough
to get some depth with the customer.
So we looked at that and of course those were
the people who had really great sales calls,
but again there were a couple people in there
makin' just as many calls as the other people
that made a lot of calls, calls were just
as long as the other people, but yet there
were a couple people the calls were just different,
they just felt different, there was that thing,
that thing again.
What was that thing?
So we were getting close to the end of the
project and I was with this one sales rep
and this had a transformational effect on
me.
I was with this one sales rep and I should
tell you I've been doing ride-alongs with
sales reps for a long time so I added it up
the other day it was some amazing amount where
I'd been on like a thousand sales calls or
some unbelievable number like that.
So I'm with this one sales rep, I spent two
days with her, did the usual where we're coding.
How many questions do they ask?
How long are they with the customer?
How many calls do they make?
We also did these one on one interviews where
we asked 'em all these questions.
And this rep was just amazing.
Like I said I've been with a lot of sales
reps and she was amazing.
And again I don't know what her numbers looked
like but I know an awesome, kick butt sales
rep when I'm with one and she was one of those.
So at the end of this two days with her we're
at the airport in Phoenix, Arizona, and oh
by the way just as an aside, if you ever go
out to work with a salesperson or you're making
calls yourself, July in Phoenix is not a time
when you wanna be getting in and out of your
car 12 times in a given day much less two
days in a row.
I'm just saying.
So that's just my little tip to you.
So we've had this two days getting in and
out of the car in July in Phoenix, but she's
a rock star sales rep.
So I'm sitting in the car with her and I thought,
"I'm gonna ask her a question, I'm gonna ask
her a question I haven't asked anybody else."
So I said, "What do you think about when you
go on sales calls?
What's in your brain?"
So she kind of looks, now we're in the car
at the airport so I don't know why she thinks
it's like this big secret, kinda looks conspiratorial
and she goes, "Well," like someone's gonna
hear us, "I don't tell many people this but
I'll tell you.
Something happened to me when I was first
in this job, I'd been in it a couple of months,"
and she said, "I was in one of my doctor's
offices and," this particular company sold
a drug that handled a lot of the conditions
associated with arthritis so she was calling
on a rheumatologist.
And so she said, "So I'm in one of my doctor's
offices and of course there's all the doctors
and nurses dressed in their uniforms, there's
all the patients and they don't look very
good and I'm there in a suit with my name
badge on so I kind of stand out."
She said, "So I'm in the hall and I'm talking
to the doctor and this elderly woman comes
up to me and taps me and she says, 'Excuse
me miss are you the rep for this drug?'"
And she said, "Yes ma'am I am."
She said, "The woman looked at me and said,
'I just wanna thank you.
Because of you I have a life.
[pause]
This doctor prescribed that to me and now
I can travel, I can get down on the floor
with my grandkids and play with them.
You gave me my life back and I wanna thank
you.'"
And she said, "I realized right then and there
my job matters."
She said, "So I think about that grandmother
every single day when I go to work, when it's
hard to get into the doctor's office, when
I'm havin' all kinds of issues with insurance
companies, when the nurses are too busy,"
she says, "I always know my job is to help
people like her and that's my higher purpose
and that's why I'm here."
[pause]
Wow!
So I get on the plane, go home, fly from Phoenix
to Atlanta so I have plenty of time to think
and this just sat with me and I thought, like
I said I mean I worked with hundreds and hundreds
of reps and thousands of sales calls, but
this really set with me because I hadn't heard
anybody speak exactly that way before.
And so I thought about it and I thought about
this sense of purpose.
And so I went back to the transcripts from
the other interviews and I thought, "I wonder
if anybody else talked about this."
And so when I first looked through the transcripts
I didn't see anything, I didn't see it.
But then when I looked closer, then when I
looked closer, a little deeper in the anecdotal
comments it was there, it was completely there.
It was there with the salesperson that said,
"You know what my dad was a doctor, their
jobs are hard, I wanna make it easier."
It was there with the salespeople that said,
"I wanna help these nurses, I wanna help these
patients, I think about that a lot, it's important."
And so I looked through and I thought, "Yeah
there it is, yeah there it is."
And so at the end of the study the biotech
company came to us and they said, "We want
you to identify who do you think," keep in
mind we don't know the numbers of these sales
people all we saw was the behavior.
They said, "We want you to identify who do
you think the top, top performers?"
And I wanna be really clear everybody we worked
with was a good, solid performer.
But what they wanted us to identify is who
do you think the top performers are 'cause
they had a certain percent of the people that
outsold everybody else.
And so I went back, I looked through the transcripts
and I found seven reps who had all exhibited
that sense of purpose.
And I said, "This is who I think the top seven
are."
I was a hundred percent right, one hundred
percent right.
And the only real difference between them
and their counterparts when you looked at
all these other measurements were they carried
that sense of purpose 'cause they knew that
their jobs made a difference, they knew it
mattered.
And so compare that one sales rep that I worked
with that I've described to you with her saying,
"I hold this grandmother in my heart," compare
her with what's going on inside the heads
of most of the other salespeople.
Now this is a company where the salespeople
are very well paid, salespeople have the opportunity
to earn bonuses, salespeople can go on these
big, fancy trips every year.
Who do you think is gonna be more effective:
the person who's going into their sales calls
thinking, "I need to close this 'cause I really
wanna win the trip, I wanna be the top performer,"
or the person who's showing up going, "I am
saving lives, this is important?"
Who's gonna be more assertive?
[pause]
Yeah, so here's what I want you to do, I want
you to do another quick exercise for me.
I want you to do this one on paper first and
then I want you to do it with each other.
And you guys can be a group of three.
So what I want you to do is I want you to
think about a time in your job, it can be
this job or another job, any job you want,
when you made a difference to someone, when
you made a difference at work.
So what I want you to do is I just want you
to take one minute and jot down some notes
'cause I really want you to think very deeply
about this: when did you do something at work
that made a difference to someone?
And then I want you to share it with the rest
of the group.
[pause]
Come on I heard y'all talkin', tell me what
you described?
>>male #3: [inaudible]
>>Lisa Earle McLeod: Uh-huh.
>>Lisa Earle McLeod: Okay.
>>male #3: And they were kind of shocked [inaudible]
and [inaudible]
>>Lisa Earle McLeod: Okay.
>>male #3: [inaudible]
>>Lisa Earle McLeod: Right.
So what do you remember about that?
How long ago was that?
>>male #3: It was in June.
>>Lisa Earle McLeod: It was June.
So what do you remember about it?
You said they were shocked, what do you remember
about that?
>>male #3: They were just really happy.
>>Lisa Earle McLeod: Uh-huh.
>>male #3: [inaudible]
>>Lisa Earle McLeod: Okay.
>>male #3: [inaudible] They were surprised
that [inaudible]
>>Lisa Earle McLeod: Uh-huh.
>>male #3: [inaudible]
>>Lisa Earle McLeod: Uh-hum.
>>Lisa Earle McLeod: Right.
>>male #3: [inaudible]
>>Lisa Earle McLeod: But they were surprised?
What else did you all come up with?
What other things?
[pause]
>>female #1: [inaudible] but I feel like I
have, so our client [inaudible]
>>Lisa Earle McLeod: Right.
>>female #1: and great part of our job [inaudible]
is working [inaudible] they need --
>>Lisa Earle McLeod: Okay.
>>female #1: go to their client.
So I think one of the ways that I've made
a difference is when they request kind of
non-revenue generating things like --
>>Lisa Earle McLeod: Um-hum.
>>female #1: [inaudible] and we get back to
them with [inaudible] really quickly --
>>Lisa Earle McLeod: Um-hum.
>>female #1: [inaudible]
>>female #1: So it's not like a specific thing
but it's more like [inaudible]
>>Lisa Earle McLeod: Right.
Do you remember instances of doing that?
>>female #1: Uh-huh.
>>Lisa Earle McLeod: And what was the client's
response?
>>female #1: The client is just very appreciative.
>>Lisa Earle McLeod: Okay.
>>female #1: They were very surprised that
we could get it that fast.
>>Lisa Earle McLeod: Okay.
Well now let me ask you a question: when we
started off I asked you to describe to your
partners what you did for a living.
And now I just asked you to describe a time
when you made a difference at work.
Did you notice the difference in the way those
two experiences felt?
[pause]
What was the difference?
How did you feel different the second time?
What was the difference between the second
time and the first time?
>>male #4: The second time was more emotional.
>>Lisa Earle McLeod: It's more emotional.
>>male #4: More passionate
>>Lisa Earle McLeod: More passionate.
What did you notice about the other person
when they were describing it the second time?
Was there a difference in the way they described
how they made a difference to someone versus
when they described their job?
>>male #5: [inaudible]
>>Lisa Earle McLeod: Doesn't sound as causal?
More earnest?
>>female #2: [inaudible]
>>Lisa Earle McLeod: More earnest.
Did you all notice anything?
Differences in the way you felt or the way
they seemed.
[pause]
Did their voices change?
>>female #3: A little more excited.
>>Lisa Earle McLeod: There's more energy,
there's more excitement.
That feeling that you had when you described
how you made a difference to someone, that's
the feeling that I wanna focus on, that I
want you to be able to take into your interactions
with customers.
'Cause that feeling taps into something very,
very powerful that we all have inside of us
'cause we all have a need, there's two fundamental
human needs: we want connection and we want
meaning.
We wanna have close personal relationships
with other people and we want to know that
what we're doing with our time counts for
something, that it matters, that we make a
difference.
This is a fundamental human need; transcends
age, transcends job, transcends culture.
We wanna know that our lives count for something.
And when you talked about the time you made
a difference you tapped into that.
So you tapped into a much deeper level of
your heart, your soul, your head, and all
of that; you went deeper with that and that's
where you engaged your emotions.
You know I didn't always know this, I was
very much on an achievement oriented path
when I was in my 20's.
And when I was in my late 20's and I was pregnant
with my first child I lost my mother to breast
cancer.
And so I was 29 and she was 53, which seemed
very young at the time and now it seems even
younger.
And I remember sitting there at her funeral,
and perhaps you all have had this experience
at a funeral.
My mother was a teacher and a lot of her students
spoke and they talked about the impact that
she'd had on their lives.
Some of the neighbors spoke, my mother's a
community activist, and she talked about how
she'd made a difference in the community.
I and her other children spoke about how she'd
made a difference to us.
And I just remember sitting there thinking,
"This is what everybody wants; everybody wants
to know that their life really matters."
And perhaps you've had this similar experience
at a funeral where you're sitting there thinking,
"Gosh I wish that he or she was here to hear
this [chuckles] because this was a really
big deal and I bet they didn't even know how
much of a difference they made to all these
people [chuckles] and now they're dead and
they're not here.
It would be way better if they could have
heard this."
I don't know if you've ever had that experience
at a funeral where you're just amazed when
you add up the sum of a person's life.
Wow, they had a really big impact.
And so that moment was when I realized that
that's what I want, I wanna know that my life
counts, I wanna know that my life matters.
And I realized so does everybody else and
so that really led me on a search for meaning
and purpose and to find ways to infuse that
into everything I did.
And it's a shame when we miss it, when we
miss what a big impact we have.
I said I'm sitting there thinking, "Gosh I
wonder if my mother even knew this," and in
all likelihood she didn't.
The reality was she probably didn't.
'Cause what happens is we get so busy with
our day to day lives and we do this and we
run from this list and I've got this list
and I'm doing this and I'm doing this and
we fail to recognize the impact that we're
actually having on all the people around us.
And we fail to appreciate what a difference
we actually do make.
And this is real shame, it's a shame for two
really important reasons: it's a shame because
we don't get to experience the joy of knowing
how much we matter and so we miss it; and
it's also a shame because when we don't realize
the impact that we have on other people we're
not as intentional in the way that we interact
with them.
What was the word you said the second time,
Rachel?
>>Rachel: Casual.
>>Lisa Earle McLeod: The first time was more
casual and the second time --
>>Rachel: Earnest.
>>Lisa Earle McLeod: and the second time was
more earnest.
So the first time was more casual, the second
time was more earnest.
'Cause when we realize, "I'm having an impact
on this person," we elevate ourselves, we
step into it in a bigger, bolder way.
So how does this apply to sales?
It completely applies to sales and that's
where this whole notion of a noble sales purpose
comes in –
[pause]
because what I've seen is the salespeople
who have absolute clarity about how they make
a difference to customers, the impact that
they have on customers, not only outsell and
outperform the other salespeople but they
like their jobs a lot more; they're a lot
happier because they know that what they're
doing counts for something.
So I wanna tell you a story about a friend
of mine who's in politics.
She's worked in a number of Congressional
offices and Senate offices, she's worked on
a bunch of big campaigns and I was talking
to her a couple years ago and she said just
a casual comment, she said, "You know in every
office there's always one TB."
And I said, "What's a TB?"
Kind of rolled her eyes and she goes, "A TB
is a true believer.
They're the starry eyed optimist who still
believes they can make a difference in the
world."
And she was kinda quiet but she goes, "But
you know what?
Here's the thing all the jaded staffers don't
talk about: everybody else in the office is
secretly jealous of the true believer 'cause
they all wish they were a TB too."
And so I thought about that, she said this
to me a couple years ago and I've really pondered
that and what I finally came to realize is
the reason that everybody's jealous of the
true believer is 'cause deep down in here
--
[pause]
we're all a TB too, we just want permission
for it to come out.
[pause]
'Cause we've got this environment it's kinda
strange where somehow it's weird to really
care passionately at work, like it's somehow
unproductive, it's like the most bizarre thing
like, "The more serious I am, the more things,"
and I know you guys aren't serious 'cause
I'm sittin' here starin' at a pool table and
a foosball table so [chuckles] I realize that.
But this whole notion of being making a difference
at work, that somehow that's like this starry
eyed, optimistic thing that only fools care
about.
But it's been proven time and time again that
this is actually what makes people more productive.
So the good news is here at Google, if you
look and I'll move the chart here so you can
see it, you already know what it is, you all
have a very, very powerful mission statement
already.
[sound of pages being turned]
But I also know that you're Google.
This is great, this is amazing, this is world
changing, but I also know that great is not
good enough for you.
So what I'm gonna do with the rest of our
time together is I wanna work with you to
take this and translate it into sales, into
how you make a difference for your customers,
for your customers, the individuals that you
call on.
How you can take this and translate it into
what I call a personal noble sales purpose.
Because when you have that at the front and
center of your brain it changes the way that
you interact with people.
So I'm gonna give you a couple of examples
of clients of mine that have NSP's.
I'm gonna give you a couple of examples and
then I'm gonna ask you to as I go through
this next section I want you to be thinking
about the impact that you have on customers.
So one of my customers sells project management
software for the construction industry.
So it'd be very easy for them to say, "What
do we do?
We sell project management software to the
construction industry and we're gonna be the
market leader, we're gonna be the best," and
all those things.
[pause]
We changed that and their NSP, their noble
sales purpose is now --
[pause]
"We help people create a better world.
"
[pause]
Actually it's "We help people build a better
world."
I need to get all of these straight in my
head.
We help people build a better world.
And so you think about that, think back to
that biotech rep, some of the other reps are
thinkin', "I sell drugs."
She's thinking, "I change lives, I heal people."
Think back to that and now think about these
people that sell project management software.
It doesn't have to be about healing the sick.
They sell project management software to the
construction industry; it's a pretty self
explanatory thing, but what they are passionate
about is helping people build a better world;
make it faster, make it safer, make it better.
That's what they're passionate about so that's
how they show up for their sales calls.
[pause]
Make sense?
I have another client that sells IT services
for small businesses and they used to say,
"Our mission is to be the world's leading
provider or America's leading provider of
IT services for small business."
And one time we were in a meeting and we were
talking, this was about two years ago when
I first started really understanding the power
that a noble sales purpose could have on an
organization.
And so we were in a meeting and we were talking
about what they do for customers and one of
the sales people said it, he said, "You know
what it's really about making small businesses
more successful."
Everyone went, "Yeah, that's right."
And I remember the salesperson was sitting
like right there and the CEO was right here
he goes, "That's it, that's it."
And he like jumps up and he says, "That's
what we do.
We help make small businesses more successful."
And that then became a filter for everything
they did.
Is what we're doing helping small businesses
be more successful then we should do it.
If it's not we shouldn't do it.
So do you see what that is, that's very, very
different than describing what you do is describing
why you do it and it's absolutely critical.
So here's what I want you do to now: I want
you to partner up again and just do this to
start, we're gonna work on this and get it
down by the end of the session, I just want
you to describe how you help your customers
and don't give it too much thought, don't
think you gotta get the exact right words
just blather on about it for a couple minutes.
Just like you were talking about how you made
a difference, talk a little more about how
you help customers and then I'm gonna ask
you some questions about that.
[pause]
[people speaking to each other in background]
>>Lisa Earle McLeod: Okay.
[pause]
[people speaking to each other in background]
>>Lisa Earle McLeod: Okay.
So we're small so I'm gonna ask you to share
with the group.
So what are some of the things that you help
your customers do?
How do you make a difference on a daily basis
to customers?
What did you all come up with?
[pause]
When I make eye contact with you there's no
getting away from it.
[laughter]
>>Lisa Earle McLeod: [chuckles]
>>male #6: [inaudible]
>>Lisa Earle McLeod: Um-hum.
So improve the productivity of the programmers.
What effect does that have on the programmers
when you improve their productivity?
>>male #6: [inaudible]
>>Lisa Earle McLeod: So you make work more
fun?
Make work easier?
Okay.
So are you starting to get, do you see the
shift here?
It's about the impact that you have on the
people that you do your work for.
>>female #4: I guess [inaudible]
>>Lisa Earle McLeod: Uh-huh.
>>female #4: [inaudible]
>>Lisa Earle McLeod: Okay.
How does it make their job easier and then
what impact does it have on their business?
>>female #4: [inaudible]
>>Lisa Earle McLeod: Okay.
And so what effect does it have on them when
they get that research and insights?
>>female #4: [inaudible]
>>Lisa Earle McLeod: Okay.
So --
[pause]
to hone in on this, if you think about how
you're helping them what I hear you saying
is that you are helping them optimize their
money and drive business for their customers.
Yeah, so you help people attract business.
So you help people attract customers.
As a business owner someone that helps me
attract customers is very, very important
in my life.
[laughs]
What else?
What other things?
How else do you make a difference to customers?
Anybody.
>>female #5: I talked about how I help my
customers drive the most sales.
>>Lisa Earle McLeod: Okay.
>>female #5: [inaudible]
So you help customers.
So you mentioned that some of your customers
are Pier I, you say, so what happens when
Pier I drives more sales?
>>female #5: They drive more sales they have
a better reputation --
>>Lisa Earle McLeod: Uh-hum.
>>female #5: they have better earnings columns.
>>Lisa Earle McLeod: Um-hum.
>>female #5: they improve their margin.
And what happens as a result of that?
>>female #5: They become more profitable.
>>Lisa Earle McLeod: Um-hum.
What happens
to their employees?
>>female #5: They are happier.
>>Lisa Earle McLeod: Yeah.
So employees are happier, more beautiful things,
I mean I think about Pier I, more beautiful
things are in people's homes --
>>female #5: Right.
>>Lisa Earle McLeod: employees get to, they
add employees --
>>female #5: Right.
>>Lisa Earle McLeod: the stores are well run.
Have you ever worked at a store, any of you
ever worked retail?
The only thing worse than working in a busy
retail store is working in a non-busy retail
store.
[laughs] That's the only thing worse.
And so I encourage you, we're gonna keep doing
this, but I encourage you to think about the
impact that you have on the human beings,
because again remember everybody wants connection
and meaning.
And so yes we are all about making our customers
more profitable, that's what we live and breathe
for, we're all about helping them attract
more customers to their businesses.
Play it out one more level and say, "What
impact is that going to have on these people
that I'm working with?"
Can you see the difference where you take
it?
'Cause when you described how you made a difference
to a customer first you started kind of broad
but then your faces lit up, I don't know if
you noticed this, but when you started talking
about that one single person that you made
a difference to, your faces changed and you
started to become, that was when you started
to become more emotional and more animated.
I'll give you an example of this in a personal
situation.
I told you I'd talk to you about how you can
use purpose in a personal situation.
Are any of you parents?
Parent, parent.
Any of you have parents?
So you've been on one side or both sides of
this whole parenting thing.
So as you know if you are a parent and if
you have parents there are a lot of very mundane,
boring jobs involved in parenting; a lot of
mundane, boring tasks involved.
If you don't have children this is a heads
up for you.
All parts of it are not fabulous, many parts
are.
But one of the things I realized as I started
this work on purpose is it doesn't just apply
to the salesperson/customer interaction or
the sales manager/sales rep interaction.
This level of purpose can be infused in anything
you do.
And so one of the things that I set for myself
early on was I said, "I wanna have a sense
of purpose as a parent."
And so this might sound rather grandiose but
it's worked for me for a lot of years.
And so one of the things that I said, one
day I was coming home and I'd had one of those
days, and we've all had one of those days,
as I said you've either been the parent or
the child or both in this situation where
the parent has just had a really long day
and they're really tired and they're coming
home and their hand is on the doorknob and
they know when they open that door they're
gonna hear, "What's for dinner?
She hit me!"
And you're just kind of going, "Okay."
And I just had this flash moment one time
when I put my hand on the doorknob and I thought,
--
[pause]
"On the other side of this door is a future
President of the United States or Secretary
of State.
Get it together!" [laughs]
And so for me instead of thinking about, "I
gotta do this, I gotta make the dinner, I
gotta write the check, I gotta do the drive,
I gotta do this, I gotta this," entering in
that task list mentality, instead of thinking
about that I think, "I'm raising a global
leader and I need to step up."
[pause]
I don't do it every day but on the days when
I do it's a call for me to bring my best self
to that job.
And so the same thing happens in sales.
If I go in thinking, "I need to sell this
stuff, I need to get 'em on this campaign,
I need to get 'em to do this," I'm gonna do
pretty well, I mean for heaven sakes you guys
are Google it's gonna go well for you.
But what happens if we bring this whole other
level of intentionality to it and we show
up with a noble sales purpose to say, "You
know what I help this company grow and that
creates jobs for these people?
I help this company grow and they put beautiful
things in people's homes."
Who are some of your other customers?
Shout 'em out.
Who else do you guys work with?
Huh?
>>someone in audience: [inaudible]
>>Lisa Earle McLeod: You're on the Home Depot
team?
Oh okay, so no wonder you two sat apart.
[laughs]
[laughter]
Yeah so you're on the Home Depot Team, you're
on the Lowe's Team so we'll talk in generalities
about the specifics.
[chuckles]
But if you think about that and you think
about how many great things happen at Home
Depot and Lowe's?
Yeah, I mean, I mean --
>>someone in audience: [inaudible]
>>Lisa Earle McLeod: you're building a home,
I mean you're building a home.
I mean I think of how much money I've spent
in both of those two places, oh my word.
And you think, "You're building a home."
You know the other thing you're doin' is if
I go online and I can get that guy to get
my water heater fixed in 12 hours, that's
huge, that is huge.
I'm not gonna tell you who responded faster
'cause --
[laughter]
I don't want you to fight between the two
of you but that is exactly what happened.
But you think about this level of purpose
that, "I'm not just doin' bits and bytes and
this and that, what I'm doin' is I'm helpin'
these people create a successful business
and that's my purpose."
So let me give you a framework, a way to think
about your business and to show you how all
this fits together.
This is what we call our Six P Model.
It's helpful to look at a visual model and
think about your business in this way.
So in any given business we have profit, that's
the thing, the bottom line, what's our revenue,
what's our margin, etcetera.
We have processes within the business: how
do we get things from here to there?
How does data move through?
What are our processes in the business?
What do we actually sell?
What are our products?
What's our go to market strategy?
That's where sales and marketing sits, it's
in promotion.
And then who are our people and what are we
gonna do with all our people?
Who needs to do what?
And all of these are inter-connected and there's
a creative tension amongst all of these, a
natural tension.
Perhaps have you seen that in your organization
with the people who wanna develop new products
maybe have some tension with the finance people
or the people in training maybe have some
tension with the process people.
Have you seen that happen?
There's a natural tension.
What happens when one of these gets over emphasized?
[pause]
Have you ever seen an organization where profit
was overemphasized?
[pause]
What happens?
>>female #6: [inaudible]
>>Lisa Earle McLeod: Um-hum.
>>Lisa Earle McLeod: More and more and more
and more and more.
>>female #6: [inaudible]
>>Lisa Earle McLeod: Yeah.
What happens over the long haul when profit
is overemphasized?
[pause]
Did it make a lot of money?
It always comes back in the end doesn't it?
If you've ever worked for a place where the
people found themselves saying, "All anyone
cares about here is money."
I can tell you that's a business that two
or three years from now will not be making
that much money.
[pause]
What about when process gets overemphasized?
Have you ever worked for a business that did
that?
Ever been part of a business that did a lean
initiative or a Six Sigma initiative?
[pause]
Do you come out of that more joyful?
>>male #7: [inaudible]
>>Lisa Earle McLeod: Right, right.
It's not that process is a bad thing, every
organization needs process.
It's when something is overemphasized.
And I could go on and on with this.
When products, even when people are overemphasized.
It's the tension between all of these.
But let me tell you where purpose fits into
this, if you think about this that's what's
missing here.
This is what a purpose does for you: a purpose
becomes your center, it becomes like your
North Star 'cause that's what keeps everything
together.
Sometime have you ever heard people say, "We
have a pendulum problem in business?"
Now we have a kind of all over the place problem
because business is so complicated now.
But having a purpose; what do we wake up every
day to do?
And this is why it's important to have one
in sales.
When I know very succinctly and very deeply
on an emotional level how I make a difference
to a customer that becomes my North Star,
that becomes the thing that guides me.
It guides me in my decision making and it
guides me in my sales behavior.
So think about who would you rather have call
on you: the person that's calling on you to
say, "I wanna close this and I wanna close
this and I wanna get 'em to do this," or the
person that's calling on you saying, "I'm
gonna help your business be more successful,
that is my purpose, that is why I'm here to
help you grow this business, help you create
more jobs, help you satisfy your customers?"
In the case of your two customers, "To help
people create better homes.
That's what I wanna help you with."
That sales call has a completely different
energy.
Remember when I talked about those salespeople
who were just a little bit different, just
a little bit different?
It was that sense of purpose bringing that
into the sales call.
And there's been a lot of research done on
this, on a sense of purpose.
Jim Collins in Built to Last and in Good to
Great demonstrated beyond a shadow of a doubt
purpose and value driven companies outperform
the market by 16 to 1, they outperform their
competitors by 6 to 1.
Daniel Pink's research in Drive, the secret
about what motivates us.
What do you think motivates people?
[pause]
Hum?
Yeah, it's not the carrot or the stick; he
totally debunked that.
It's autonomy, mastery, and purpose.
Another bestselling book of late, The Progress
Principle, where they looked at the work diaries
of thousands and thousands of employees, where
they charted out what they were really thinking
at work; they call it their inner work lives.
The thing that had the biggest contribution
to creating a positive work environment, and
a positive work environment was where people
liked it and they got a lot done, was when
people had meaningful progress towards a shared
purpose, towards meaningful work.
So the research is absolutely, absolutely
clear, purpose matters.
Now again the great thing at Google is you
all do have clarity around this, you know
how you're making a difference in the world.
But what happens is despite all this research
and despite all this stuff that's out there,
a lot of times it falls apart when you get
to sales 'cause what takes precedent in sales?
[pause]
Hum?
The revenue, the numbers; revenue is important.
I've been in sales all my life, I run my own
business.
Revenue is extremely important but one of
the things that Peter Drucker said really
struck with me is, "Profit is not the purpose
of a business but rather the test of its validity."
Think about that.
Profit is not the purpose of a business but
the test of its validity.
[pause]
And so I think your company knows that already;
a lot of companies know that, but what happens
is when it comes to the sales conversation
it ends up being all about the targets and
the revenue and we gotta get this and we gotta
get this and we gotta get this.
It's not because we're inherently bad, evil,
or greedy people.
No it's just because sales lends itself to
that.
That's why we have to be really intentional
about pulling purpose to the front.
You wanna say somethin'.
[pause]
So I'm gonna give you an example here of what
happens when it all becomes about the money;
this is an extreme example, sometimes you
in the extreme we see what we don't wanna
be.
The faces are blurred on this to protect the
innocent.
How many of you like buying a car?
[pause]
>>female #7: I just bought one [inaudible].
>>Lisa Earle McLeod: Really?
Do you realize, everyone else can't see, I
wish the camera could capture your facial
expression now.
Your facial expression was, "I just bought
one."
I mean literally like, "I just passed a kidney
stone."
I mean that's what your face was like.
[laughs] So I take it, it was not a great
experience for you.
Now I want you to think this through: now
car salespeople, I do not think they are inherently
evil people, but when you look at most despised
professions, the list, the only people that
fall below car salespeople are Congressmen.
[laughter]
The only people [chuckles] I'm not kidding,
I don't make this stuff up.
I Googled it, it must be true, but anyhow.
So think about this though, this is an amazing
thing that happens in this industry.
So think about the automotive industry, they
have excellent engineers don't they?
They have amazing engineers, they have great
consumer research, they're literally -- my
cousin used to run a huge manufacturing facility
for one of the Big Three and so they do all
this research to find out how they can make
our lives better with these cars.
Then they have these great engineers, how
can they make us feel better, enjoy driving
more, support our families better by taking
all these kids?
So they do all this research, they have these
great engineers, they have great ads.
Aren't a lot of the car ads great ads?
I mean you watch the ad and you think, "Wow,
this could have a huge impact on my life.
I could feel so much better if I had this
car."
So it's all there.
But what happens when you get—
[pause]
to the salesperson?
When you go to the car dealership do they
ask you any questions at all about what impact
will this car have on your life?
How will your life be better or different
as a result of this?
Do they ever ask you any of those questions?
No what did they ask you?
>>female #8: [inaudible]
>>Lisa Earle McLeod: Yeah.
You ready to close it now?
How much a month can you expend?
And these days, do you have good credit?
Of course if they asked you if you work for
Google, hey okay [inaudible].
But yeah because the whole conversation is
around how can I close you right now and it
shows from the moment you walk in there.
Can't you just feel it?
Now why do you think that is?
Is it because they're bad people?
Is it because they're evil people?
>>female #9: [inaudible]
>>Lisa Earle McLeod: 'Cause they're only numbers
driven, that is their sole focus.
'Cause what are the conversations that the
sales manager has with the sales rep?
The reason the sales rep only talks to you
about pricing/closing is because that's all
the sales manager talks to the sales rep about.
When they have those sales meetings what do
they talk about?
How many you gonna sell?
When you gonna sell it?
How are you gonna close it?
How fast can you get it done?
When are you gonna do it?
There's nothing wrong with having a strong
sense of urgency about sales.
Trust me, I run a company, this is an important
thing, we wanna have a sense of urgency.
But when you miss that sense of purpose, when
that's absent, the interaction with the customer
is just awful.
And this is an extreme example, but this is
an industry that has done it to itself; they
have invested in every aspect of that industry
but they have not changed the way they sell,
and that is why I'm still driving [bad audio]
year old Lexus because I cannot bear to go
to the car dealership because it is an assault
on my soul to be with a bad salesperson and
so I'm gonna drive it until the wheels fall
off, I cannot even stand it.
[laughter]
But we do not want this to happen to you;
this is a very, very extreme example.
So here's what I want you to do:
[pause]
there's Google's very powerful mission statement.
You've had a couple of minutes to talk about
how you make a difference to customers and
so I just want you to get started on this;
it takes a while to do it, but I want you
to get started on it and what I want you to
do just pair up and I want you to try and
come up with some sort definitive statement
about how you make a difference to customers.
Now I gave you those examples my customers
use; one of them is we help people build a
better world; gave you the example of I'm
raising a future President of the United States
of America, maybe that'd be helpful to you,
I don't know.
Gave you the other example of we help small
businesses be more successful.
[pause]
The thing a good noble sales purpose has in
it is it is very clear about the impact that
you have on customers, it's concrete, so it's
real it's not just some airy, fairy thing.
So like we help small businesses be more successful,
they really do that and it's exciting, it's
exciting, it's a reason to believe.
So here's what I want you to think about,
I want you to take a couple of minutes to
do this, I want you to think about the impact
that you have on your customers or your team
members, how you're different than your competitors;
and I use the word competitors to mean the
people that you're competing for dollars with.
So as you said the newspaper, how are you
different than that?
And you don't have to make a big long list,
but how are you different?
And then the third thing is: think back to
how you felt when you talked about that time
when you made a difference to somebody.
On your best day what do you love about your
job?
So it doesn't have to include all three of
these but this is just some prompts to get
you started.
So I want you to take a couple minutes, talk
about it, see what you can come up with, and
this will be a start.
[pause]
[people speaking to one another in background]
Great.
Perfect.
[pause]
[people speaking to one another in background]
>>female #10: [inaudible] more trying to understand
[inaudible] trying to grow [inaudible]
>>Lisa Earle McLeod: Right.
>>female #10: [inaudible]
>>Lisa Earle McLeod: So you're really, yeah,
you care.
>>female #10: I do things that [inaudible]
I feel lucky to be in a great company where
it is important to my boss that we care about
our customers --
>>Lisa Earle McLeod: Um-hum.
>>female #10: [inaudible] that you don't just
care about [inaudible]
>>Lisa Earle McLeod: Um-hum.
Well it isn't ironic those are the companies
that make the most money.
>>female #10: Right.
[inaudible]
>>Lisa Earle McLeod: You can feel it.
I'm gonna show you something in a second about
how you're, that thing I showed you Rachel
about how your subconscious feelings are being
read by your customers –
>>Rachel: [inaudible]
>>Lisa Earle McLeod: and they don't even know
it.
So is it okay if I go to like 2:30?
>>Rachel: Yep.
>>Lisa Earle McLeod: Is that okay?
>>Rachel: [inaudible]
>>Lisa Earle McLeod: Okay, okay 'cause [inaudible]
[pause]
So tell me what you all came up with.
This is a start so if we had more time we'd
work through it and we'd get 'em all perfect.
You had a great one though, why don't you
tell me what yours is.
>>female #11: Mine is to help my clients grow
their businesses and become more successful.
>>Lisa Earle McLeod: Okay.
So the thing I would add to that is I would
say instead of "to help my clients" I would
say "I help my clients."
>>female #11: Okay.
[pause]
And so I help my clients grow their businesses
and be more successful.
It's pretty succinct and simple.
Rachel you're in training so what did you
come up with?
>>Rachel: My customers are Googlers.
>>Lisa Earle McLeod: Right.
>>Rachel: So I arm Googlers with skills and
knowledge so that they can have more successful
and effective at work and home [inaudible]
>>Lisa Earle McLeod: Okay.
Did you come up with one?
Are you close?
>>male #8: Yeah, I guess [inaudible]
>>Lisa Earle McLeod: Okay, great.
>>male #8: [inaudible] I empower the end user
[inaudible]
>>Lisa Earle McLeod: You empower the end user
to find your customers.
>>male #8: Actually I [inaudible]
>>Lisa Earle McLeod: Right.
>>male #8: empower customers [inaudible]
>>male #8: [inaudible]
>>Lisa Earle McLeod: Right.
So you empower, so you have this vision of
all these people out there finding your client
--
>>male#8: Right.
>>Lisa Earle McLeod: Yeah.
Can you feel the difference in that?
Are you starting to sense the difference in
that versus, and again you guys have a great
mission statement but when you think about
what you're bringing to that individual customer
interaction there's a slight twist on it.
[bad audio] the difference?
>>female #12: [inaudible] you words are more,
are stronger, the word empower is just [inaudible]
>>Lisa Earle McLeod: Um-hum.
>>female #12: Yeah.
>>female #12: I don't know I feel like it's
just, even in the language you used to describe
it --
>>Lisa Earle McLeod: Right.
>>female #12: is more motivating.
>>Lisa Earle McLeod: It is.
And see this is, I'm glad you noticed that
because this is the thing that a lot of times
companies who have absolute clarity of their
mission, whether they call it a mission or
a purpose, that have absolute clarity a lot
of times it needs to be tweaked for sales.
'Cause it really resonates with the product
development people and it's a great statement
to put out there to the entire company, but
what happens in sales is I need to have a
mental image of that one customer I'm calling
on.
That's why I say a noble sales purpose.
I need to have a mental image of what I do
for you specifically, that's why it's so important.
So the NSP, it's how you make a difference
to your customers and it's what you hold in
your heart when you go on sales calls.
So I'm gonna give you in the time that we
have left, we just have a couple minutes left,
so I'm gonna give you three things that you
can do to keep this front and center of your
awareness.
First thing is a mental model that you can
use when you go on sales calls.
So let's think about how a typical sales call
goes.
We've got the salesperson's agenda which is
what?
[pause]
Sell, of course it's to sell.
So we have the salesperson agenda.
I'm gonna go over to the customer see if I
can find out a little bit about them because
what do I wanna do?
I wanna bring them back over to my side so
I can sell them something.
It works; there's nothing wrong with that.
What I wanna give you is a different mental
model.
And you all have the book in front of you
so if you think salesperson/customer, different
mental model is what we call the Triangle
of Truth and it's thinking about your sales
calls in a very different way.
Your sales calls are no longer I'm trying
to get the customer over to my agenda, you're
sales calls are in service of your NSP, your
noble sales purpose.
So if I'm showing up to help my customers
be more successful or if I'm showing up to
help customers find my customers then everything
single thing I do on that sales call is in
service of that.
Why is this so important?
This is important because one of the things
that salespeople struggle with is being able
to master the, I wanna help the client and
I need to close this deal; that quagmire right
there.
What this does it is says you can do both
because the most successful salespeople, in
the studies I did with salespeople, the most
successful people have a both/and mentality.
So I've got a whole white paper on this.
This is really cool: if you just text SMART
to this number if you've got a cell phone
text SMART to this number and you can get
it and it'll describe this in a little more
detail.
See usually I'm not a cool person who would
have something like that, but now I am where
you just text SMART you get a paper, so there
you go.
The reason this mental model is so important
is the way you show up mentally affects the
things that you say and the presence.
When you look at human interactions and you
look at content, the actual words we say,
and mindset, which is our inner dialog that's
being revealed through our tone and our body
language, what percent do you think people
respond to?
Content versus mindset?
If you had to put percentages on those where
do you think most of the response comes from?
[pause]
Some studies show as much as 93 percent and
I'm gonna prove it.
[pause]
Where were you last night?
We just had three completely different conversations
and I said exactly the same thing.
You knew what I was thinking didn't you?
That's why this NSP, thinking about this before
you go on calls, that's why it matters 'cause
the customers can feel it.
I made it very conscious here, they can feel
it subconsciously, we're all responding to
each other subconsciously all the time.
So is it any wonder that that salesperson
that I mentioned to you who said, "I think
about that grandmother everyday and I'm gonna
heal more people like her."
Guess what I found out about that sales rep?
Number one rep in the company three years
in a row.
Are you surprised?
[pause]
No, 'cause that's what's in her head when
she goes on sales calls.
Like it or not your internal dialog is the
elephant inside every interaction.
[pause]
And so what a noble sales purpose is about
is about elevating the quality of your internal
dialog when you're in front of the customer.
So I'm gonna give you two more things real
quickly before we close.
This is the mental model that I want you to
have when you think about your sales calls.
Now I'm gonna give you a technique to present
information to customers.
How do we usually present information to customers
when we make a recommendation to customers?
Hum?
>>female #13: Slides.
>>Lisa Earle McLeod: Slides, PowerPoint, oh
my goodness.
So nothing wrong with that.
In my experience what we usually do is we
say, "Here's what I recommend and here's why."
[pause]
Isn't that the way we usually do it?
Well I'd like to suggest to you there's a
more powerful way to do that.
It's a technique I call context and framing.
If you show up for your customers and you
have a noble sales purpose and your purpose
is to make a difference in their business,
you're probably gonna be pretty proactive
about asking them questions 'cause you're
gonna need to know.
How can I create success for you if I don't
know what success looks like for you?
So when it comes time to present something
instead of saying, "Here's what I recommend
and here's why," try this instead.
Start with context: "You told me that one
of the things that you wanted to do was get
more shoppers into the store.
You appeal to younger people you wanna get
more shoppers into the store."
Frame: there's a couple ways that you could
do this.
You could do it this way, you could do this
way, you could do it this way.
"As we look at this, this one is probably
going to be the most effective for you in
helping you reach the objectives that you
set.
And so that's why I recommend this."
Did you hear the difference in that?
It's very subtle but there is a distinct difference.
So you provide the context first, then you
set up a frame, and then you deliver the message.
[pause]
It sounds backwards to us, but it's in order
for the customer.
'Cause if I say I recommend this the customer's
brain is going, "And how does that fit with
this and how does that fit with this and where
would that go with this?"
The customer's brain is doing all that.
Doing it this way I establish the context
first, "Okay we're all on the same place,
here's what we wanna do.
You said that you wanted to do this," and
I wanna be very clear on this I'm not talking
about manipulating your customers.
"Well you said and I'm gonna make you think,"
I'm not talking, I'm talking about doing this
in a very authentic, intentional way.
So if I wanna make the customers more successful
and I've uncovered what that looks like for
them, I frame it up, "Here are the things
you wanted to accomplish in the next coming
year.
Now as we look at the advertising portion
of this there's this, there's this, there's
this.
Looking at these three things I think this
is the one that would give you the most bang
for your buck and so what I recommend is this
is the way we need to implement."
Can you hear the difference in that?
That is pulling that purpose to the front
and center.
So that last thing I wanna share with you
is a management technique.
So this is what I want you to tell your managers
when you're in a conversation with your managers;
it's a technique that sales managers can use
and you can also use it to manage your manager.
So how does the typical sales managers/salesperson
conversation go when you start looking at
the numbers?
[pause]
>>female #14: They're behind or ahead or --
>>Lisa Earle McLeod: [laughs]
>>female #14: How are we gonna drive more
money [inaudible] --
>>Lisa Earle McLeod: Right.
How are we gonna do this?
And typical, I mean I've been a sales manager,
typical conversation, "When are we gonna close
it?
How much can we close?
Is there somebody else?
Have you met with all the decision makers?
Who's the competition?
What stands in the way?
Can we speed it up?"
Those types of things; anybody ever have one
of those conversations?
Those are very appropriate sales manager conversations,
but there's one more question that will make
a huge difference.
If as you look at a sales opportunity if the
manager says, --
[pause]
"How will the customer's life be different?"
That one question shifts it from being all
about you and what you need to close, to the
impact that it will have on the customer.
And this is very ironic because if I'm a salesperson
and I can paint you a picture of how the customer's
life will be different and it's a very positive
picture, that is going to create more urgency
in me as a salesperson than you telling me,
"When can you close this?"
Because it matters, now it matters.
I can't wait for their lives to be different.
I wanna have this impact on them.
It matters.
And if you can't paint a positive picture
of how their lives will be different you are
probably not going to close it anyway.
[chuckles] So that one question.
Can you hear the difference in what that does?
Remember, what do you do when you described
how you make a difference?
It was about why you did it.
This is about the why and that transforms
that sales manager conversation.
[pause]
This is the reality: quotas, targets, numbers,
they connect with your head.
When you have a sense of purpose it connects
with your heart.
And top performing salespeople have both;
they're very clear on the numbers, but they're
also very clear on how they make a difference
to their customers and that's what they keep
at the front and center.
And so that leads me to the third thing that
I told 'ya I was gonna talk to you about which
is how you pull this sense of purpose to the
front and center of all your relationships,
not just with your customers.
'Cause see here's a little secret: when you
know that you're interactions with other people
make a difference, when you know that your
life matters, that you make a difference,
you show up for it in a much bigger way; you
show up in a bigger way.
You show up as your best version of yourself.
Because having a sense of purpose in your
life is actually how you start to fall in
love with your own life 'cause that's when
you know it matters.
[pause]
So your work matters, your company matters,
your life matters, you matter.
And one of the biggest mistakes that we make
is we undervalue our lives and the impact
that we have on other people; it's a huge
mistake 'cause when you bring a sense of purpose
and you know that you make a difference everything
changes, everything changes.
And so I want you to keep that in your mind:
that your job matters, your company matters,
your life matters, and you matter, everything
that you do matters, it matters a lot.
Thanks.
[applause]